you've heard it too that people say I
don't even like country music but I do
like Kacey Musgraves yeah they're like
you're my gateway drug
thanks these days with the genre lines
being so blurred I mean that the
possibilities are endless
you know to me music falls into two
different categories that's good and bad
with three critically acclaimed studio
albums Kacey Musgraves has certainly
made her own Lane the singer-songwriter
says her love of music began when she
was just a little girl I grew up wanting
to be a singer I mean I grew up just
singing singing singing it did you sink
into a hairbrush a hairbrush
you know karaoke mic whatever broomstick
yeah just singing all the time and then
it's interesting I felt like a shift
when I moved to Nashville when I was
about 19 I've figured out that you could
have an actual career as a songwriter
and not put your face out there I was
kind of turned off by you know the whole
artists side of things and then then
we're along the way I started collecting
these songs that felt like I wouldn't
want to give him up musgraves released
her debut album back in 2013 she
insisted merry-go-round be the first
single it was an edgy choice that a
record executive told her would not work
for radio I wouldn't be proud of
changing myself to try to you know
appease to a wider range of people and
what do you say to you he said well
sometimes in this business you just have
to do things that you're not proud of
and I said that's where you and I sir
are very different you would really
prefer not to have the career you have
than to have a hit song and not be proud
of
oh my gosh I can't imagine something
more excruciating no it's not worth it
it's just not worth it to me staying
true to herself has paid off big
musgraves attributes her success to her
songwriting roots know even when you
were accepting your Grammy you said it's
all about the songs tell me about that
why that's so important to you there's a
little thing that a little light bulb
that goes off that goes that says oh
this this this is something this is an
idea this this could be
a song and it kind of presents itself I
could be in the middle of an argument
I'm like oh that's a good luck but I
guess just the whole process of taking
something from nothing that process is
something that is magical do you have an
example of where you heard something and
you said AHA that's a song all I kept
being sad I love happy and sexy happy
and sad are two emotions that I find
myself feeling a lot of the times
together I think it can be the anxiety
of knowing that the moment is about to
is you know eventually gonna end what
goes up comes down yeah you know and I
remember being in a Palm Springs tiki
bar with my now husband and we were so
in love and he was saying just these
things to me that we're bringing tears
to my eyes and I was very happy but he
was confused cuz I was crying and I was
happy but I was sad at the same time and
I felt I feel that a lot we would all
like to meet somebody that says
something that is so wonderful that it
brings tears tears
yeah musgraves and singer-songwriter
Rustin Kelly tie the knot in 2017 it's a
love story that helped inspire her
latest album Golden Hour how did you
know he was the one for you I don't know
I just knew I mean it was just like
there it is leading up to making gold an
hour I was just in a kind of a depressed
depressive space I wasn't sure what I
wanted to do creatively and I feel like
I always feel a little bit depressed
when I feel lost creatively I took about
a year to where I could just be in town
and catch up on the simple parts of life
that I had missed you know being on tour
it's like I'm needing to live life and
that will feed new songs so that's about
the time that I met Reston and needless
to say all these songs started pouring
out did you know people thought okay now
she's in love and she's happy yeah
how can she well the music B is good
right were you worried about that I was
worried I was like I am I'm happy out
like my musics gonna suck well because
you get you trick yourself into thinking
that as a creative person that you don't
need to suffer in order to produce great
art and I think that's a terrible
mistake I've kept myself in bad
relationships before thinking good songs
will come out of it so whatever but
that's like what
like some waste of time I did get some
good songs out of it thank you did so it
came as a surprise to me when I when
this kind of whole new facet of art and
writing kind of opened up for me after
being the happiest that I had ever been
do you struggle with Fame do you worry
about Fame it's not my favorite thing
Fame I think it used to freak me out a
lot when I was younger I was really
intimidated by it but as I've gotten
older I've realized that you know you
don't there's not really anything to be
scared of like I have a wonderful
foundation with my family underneath me
my husband I know who I am do you feel
like this is your moment I mean I could
say that it's you know my moment
professionally but personally I feel
like it's its best yet you know with
leaving my 20s going into my 30s
finding kind of a new sense of self and
confidence that comes with being with
the right person and the songs that came
from that I think for me it all boils
down to my songs I feel like nothing
else would matter none of this would
matter and there's so much fluff in the
industry none of that would matter if
the songs weren't there for me